what is uh you know we were just talking
a little bit about the Russell obviously
coming out of your your town
um so many legends that come out of
Vallejo too by the way
um what is it like to kind of see
someone like Russell kind of take a
different approach to the music industry
obviously he's not really kind of right
now we get so much of the street music
from Vallejo he's kind of given us a
whole different side of the coin I tell
the Russell every time I see him he'll
tell you I call him baby Jesus right
baby Jesus like when we see Larissa We
Believe type that's really really like
when you walk around this with angel
wings and a halo around this right yeah
when you walk around this it's either go
like he's showing the way yeah and he's
not he's not putting no negativity in
the world like he pushing all positivity
like I tell that like you you're you're
going to heaven for the show like you
got to like you spreading a good message
like he wanna like you know you know
because in the Bible that they talk
about that be spreading God messages
have you been to his house for any of
his shows yet yeah
pretty crazy you got the backyard going
crazy just right in the neighborhood
yeah so and they and they so respectful
he'd be on some pay what you want to
like a mug when you're doing like that
like gonna give you 100 for a shirt
right you might have some little low
ballers but you're gonna run into
somebody that's gonna even out yeah it's
gonna even out for sure probably he then
they're getting molding even outfit so I
was gonna say uh how far are you from
compared to where his house is at or is
that kind of like you know I ain't even
invalid you talking about like where we
from though like yeah where you from
yeah like we from around the corner for
sure yeah like we both in the north the
north well hell is small that's like
really like it is very small it's as
small as an island for yeah like this
Island's bigger than Vallejo
um you obviously have been somebody who
tapped in with this what's going on in
Stockton because Stockton's kind of on
fire right now man
kind of the base cousin a little bit you
know yeah yeah a lot of people who
aren't from the bay lump Sacramento
Meadow Stockton and the bay all is one
even though they're not
[Music]
um you worked with young sloby before he
passed away talk about your guys's
relationship obviously rest in peace to
him but you know that was a big loss for
Stockton RP my [__] Mary since I tapped
in with him like you feel because he's
just been genuine for as my [__] like I
call that [__] like we just talk on
some other [__] not even Unknown music
[__] for real like he'll come pull up on
me you feel me uh I outline little plays
up from for him to go get this so you
send me all type of little [__] as my
[__]
RP that [__] man I [__] well I really
[__] with mostly I [__] with a lot of
ebk [__] though I ain't gonna lie I
[__] with Jack I [__] with jaybo
Trey B little marble I [__] with a lot
of them [__] [__] cool do you ever
do like shows in Stockton uh I did a
show in Stockton before probably an SOB
shot
I probably did a solo show like not too
long ago but that'd be so much [__]
going on I wouldn't even remember you've
been a part of some crazy [__] man for
sure I probably the last time I probably
did this uh Stockton probably like a
year or two ago I don't remember being
out there but I know a [__] did a
couple shows out there for sure yo what
was it like being a part of the Black
Panther soundtrack
because that kind of was a
moments Kendrick was on that record too
yeah that's a big deal now first of all
not a lot of people these days sharing
records with Kendrick and that's one of
the biggest movies of all time so that's
my biggest song to this day that
[__] went like double platinum
in that mother for just the song itself
and he ain't got no videos no video
nothing I feel like that was kind of
like the last hurray for SOB kinda yeah
that was like our biggest I feel like
after that [__] is when [__] kind of
started uh yeah man a lot of [__]
started happening man behind the scenes
you know how that [__] go man just some
old brother [__] though [__] fighting
behind the scenes like we brothers and
we was young you know how that [__] go
like but what was that moment like for
you like just kind of knowing you met
you're making it onto a Marvel movie
soundtrack and and Kendrick's hopping on
the record I ain't gonna lie when we
first got in the studio we got on that
[__] like
I really ain't think it was gonna really
come out he's like yep we at least got
the chance to be in the studio with that
[__] and give us what oh you guys are
in the studio with him hey we got the so
[__] really just had to mindset like
[__] at least we got up in the studio
and got the chance to defend me show
that [__] what we got for real you fan
and it's a banger but when that [__]
came out
I heard the uh Black Panther [__] came
out but [__] Ain't really think you
sent me our [__] was on there so I
really didn't even check like
[__] was just calling a [__]
like yo we made the Black Panther
soundtrack y'all [__] going crazy
[__] your first one stupid I'm like
hell nah I'm in the studio at the time
too recording I go straight to the
soundtrack I listen to that [__] the way
he put the little pause on my [__] I was
like oh I ain't gonna lie like that [__]
then they're like gave a [__]
Goosebumps right you feel me the way
that that [__] hit a [__] with the the
boy you feel me then change the tempo
for like four bars like I ain't gonna
lie that [__] I had a [__] feeling like
a champion you know like when you
growing up a [__] got you you in sports
you wanted trophies and [__] when I was
playing sports I think online really win
too many trophies right like I was
really a Streetball player I wouldn't
really you feeling me one of them ones
really really on the court so you family
[__] like that like that's a trophy for
me